the thing what I love about being a chef
is to see satisfactory off on the gas I
smile
a Dubai is such a vibrant city diversity
of people the nationality that we have
is willing fantastic wherever I am in
the world food is the focal point of
everything I do
my name is Ching and I'm a TV chef and
food writer my taste journeys have taken
me all over the world in search of great
flavors and new recipes
finally it's brought me to Dubai and I
can't wait to explore its rich and
varied food scene one bite at a time
brief Othman internationally celebrated
chef has worked in a variety of kitchens
from fine dining and exponential cuisine
to innovative pop ups food and family
have always gone hand in hand and for
chef Reef Dubai has provided the perfect
environment to raise a family and pursue
his culinary adventures hi my name is
real money and I'm from Singapore my
family would describe me as hard-working
funny and a little bit of crazy I will
describe myself easy be style pays [ __ ]
on the point so I have two kids
Aiden and Ali yeah my precious they are
my life
my grandmother was a very important
person in my family's life and one of my
favorite memories of my gran was that
she'd always make me and my brothers
packed lunches for school I'm really
excited to be meeting a father and chef
who does the same for his children today
we are making some one monkey roll
sashimi that's what is chefs lunchbox so
multifaceted divide and do you feel like
that's also a mirror for who you are
you're a serious dad you're a serious
chef it's not easy but yeah I have to
juggle it at home you have to be funny
we figure but the Y's been great it's
giving me a lot of opportunity after
meeting reefs family we head to the
waterfront fish market so that he could
show me the amazing variety of fresh
produce
Tobias coastline has to offer for a chef
who's passionate seafood I can see why
Reef was excited to bring me here
welcome to waterfront fish market the
open 24/7
throughout the year let me show you some
someone fishes since tuna the blue crab
local fishes import shellfish you just
name it they have him
oh you fresh fish this is where you get
it all from exactly plenty of choice
video choice yes once I pick some Fisher
there are one we are bringing it to my
local fish a restaurant are you hungry
I've always hungry that's it okay our
next stop book tear where one has to try
the speciality fried fish famous for the
fried fish okay and surprise
here we have the cherry fish at a
marinated with the masala curry in it
was always fun so inspect you even even
dinner there's a queue how do we stop
you so hence okay really get the mix of
spices yes of the flesh of the fish
simplicity is key I will try your food
yeah why not let's go let's go to my
restaurant and you see my tech are doing
my fish
all right here we have a sea bass
ceviche papa
uh-huh wow it's really good the fish is
delicious yeah we we get freshly two
times a week from Japan directly hmm so
here we have DJ I'm gonna see rocky beef
and the rice is from Kyoto okay only the
Emperor is eating miss rice that is
delicious
that is comfort in a bowl unbelievably
tasty by is going now a lot of
restaurant opening a lot of Bishops
coming in it's all about to achieve and
to give for the best experience to our
customer our diners you know we do have
some homegrown restaurant that made by
homegrown talent as well
I didn't realize that you could have
such a vast array of choice and
delicious food in Dubai from Street food
to fine dining and everything in between
my time in Dubai has been multifaceted
vibrant full of flavor full of culture
and I can't wait to come back
[Music]